Queries are specified in a health
quality measure format or
HQMF for short.
This is an XML standard for documenting
the content and structure of a quality
measure using an XML document
formatted based on the HL7 REM.
It consists of three levels of detail.
Metadata, such as who wrote it,
the dates over which it is valid,
who validated it, and other details
about how the measure works or is used.
Human narrative, including measured
description, data criteria,
the measure population,
and measure observations.
Finally, computer instructions
As to how to count and
compute the results of the measure.
This is a small part of the XML
in a HQMF query specification.
In this case,
it provides instructions to the computer
to only include patients who
have had their weight measured.
This might define the numerator of
a weight screening quality metric.
That as you recall from lesson two,
is a requirement in meaningful use.